je m'appelle Noémie j'ai 32 ans et je
suis éleveuse de cochon dans le Gers
[Musique]
ça va mieux que cette nuit
la réalité du métier déjà maintenant je
suis indépendante ce qui était pas le
cas avant donc là ce qui va faire mes
horaires ça va être les animaux les
besoins des animaux les besoins du
marché des clients de la salle de
découpe c'est à dire des autres éleveurs
mais tout en restant quand même
maîtresse de de mes propres choix et
j'ai l'impression de pouvoir beaucoup
plus choisir en fonction de mon éthique
et de ce que j'ai envie de faire
derrière
[Musique]
j'ai eu mon diplôme à Sciences Po en
affaires publiques en 2014 et ensuite
j'ai commencé à bosser à Hong Kong à
Londres et là j'ai eu des au bout de
plusieurs années des soucis de santé qui
ont fait que j'ai du quitter la grande
ville et aller mettre à la campagne et
en fait ça a été assez évident quand
j'ai commencé à remettre les mains dans
la terre et dans le travail de l'animal
et de la campagne je me suis dit que
c'était ça que je voulais faire de ma
vie
[Musique]
je me suis dit que j'avais envie de
contribuer du coup à quelque chose
d'autre mais pas en tout cas continuer à
cautionner un système qui m'était ouais
des pesticides des perturbateurs
endocriniens et des polluants dans notre
environnement
[Musique]
je me suis rendu compte que mon
carburant c'était l'humain et j'ai
préféré clairement orienter mes
recherches vers des endroits où on
allait être en agriculture collective et
je pense que ça correspond aussi à une
aspiration de notre génération ne pas
vouloir se retrouver tout seul isolé en
pleine campagne parce que tu es soumis
aux intempéries tu es soumis aux aléas
du climat parfois il se passe des trucs
avec tes animaux ou tes cultures qui
vont être dur à porter donc il vaut
mieux être plusieurs à les porter et je
pense que l'agriculture de demain sera
collective ou ne sera pas
[Musique]